Steve Kerr the Golden State Warriors
head coach joining us in the Continental
Tire Coaches Corner
we've been talking by the way good
morning Steve morning Dan hey doing I'm
doing okay we don't know how to
categorize Robert orys career all of
those rings so and you can't tell the
history of the NBA without Robert Horry
so is he a hall-of-famer oh that's a
great question I'm glad I'm not on the
committee that's you're right he played
such a big role in so many different
championship seasons so that VAD alone
the argument could be made that that
alone since the whole point is winning
that could be enough to get him into the
Hall of Fame because his you know his
his regular stats and career if you go
by that he's not a Hall of Fame player
and he would probably admit that to you
a very good player but he's got probably
does anybody have more rings other than
Bill Russell I don't think so although
you have what three is a player or you
have five is a player three as a coach
right yeah so you you're one ahead of
Robert Horry well you're going into the
Hall of Fame well I appreciate that when
did you get the news I just got it you
know the Commissioner sent it over to me
so yeah I'm Steve Kerr on telling me
he's gonna go into the Hall of Fame back
but you aren't Steve like you entered
your basketball career as a great
contributor but because of what you've
done as a coach you're going into the
Hall of Fame pretty amazing well I've
definitely lived in a pre charmed
existence in the NBA and even in college
I mean just playing with Jordan and
Pippen and Duncan and Robinson all these
guys and now you know here in Las Vegas
coaching with pop yes this is so much
fun but I think I think back to all the
different coaches that I've
that I played for and the way they
helped prepare me for my coaching career
I've been I've been pretty blessed
obviously but you turned down that
Nick's job with Phil Jackson and I
thought what is Steve thinking because
it felt like you were tick you were
taken and were you close to taking that
job I was very close to taking that job
and and the main attraction really was
filled because of my relationship with
him and and you know ultimately it just
came down to to talent you know the the
Warriors had a team that had already won
52 games I think the year before and I
had a lot of good advice from friends in
the coaching world and and you know
several of them said the same thing we
said as strong as your relationship
might be with with Phil you know it's
the players who ultimately make or break
your career and Golden State's got a
bunch of young talent and and and they
were right you know I mean the Warriors
were just poised to take off they were
already a really good team and ready to
get to the next level and and so I you
know obviously it worked out for dumb
pretty well yeah I think you made the
right decision but I go back to 2009 you
were the sons GM and I don't know how
close you came to trading for Steph
Curry but was it close it was yeah it
was pretty close I mean there wasn't a
handshake agreement but we thought we
had a deal pretty much done and but it
you know you learn in that job until
it's and until it's actually you've had
the phone call with the league you know
it's not official but we had a lot of
talks with the Warriors and we thought
we were we were maybe going to get staff
to come in and play behind Steve Nash
and you know kind of take over for Nash
as Nash moved on so that would have been
a hell of a hell of a loop for the Suns
but
wait wait you were gonna have curry
backup Steve Nash yeah in his first you
know his first year or two that would
have been I guess it was his first year
if stuff first year was nine ten I'll
have one of my people check that yeah
yeah so you know Nash number Nash had
still had a couple of great years left
in him at that point and if you look at
Steph's early career with the Warriors
he wasn't starting he was you know he
was a rookie
you know figuring things out yeah yeah I
just curious about that if you obviously
now you would put them in the same
backcourt together yeah you could do
that it'd be pretty small defensively
but Nellie never cared about defensive
we're talking to Steve Kerr of the
Golden State Warriors head coach if I
didn't see this season if I didn't know
anything about this season you were
gonna sum it up how would you sum it up
for me courageous it was I don't think
I've ever been more proud of the team
you know despite the fact that we didn't
win the whole thing it was just an
incredible effort to see our guys fight
and scrap and claw the way they did the
whole way through and and still almost
forced a game seven you know at the end
of the Toronto series it was just
incredible to watch our guys and their
their will their their competitive
desire I also wonder about all of the
you know the second season and you
experience this with the Bulls just how
much the extra mileage on the body
you know maybe wore down your team you
know maybe clay that was a freakish
injury I don't know if you know with KD
if maybe just the attrition like it just
after a while you're playing a lot of
games here what what kind of role do you
think that played in how this season
finished there's no question that that
takes a toll emotionally you know just
getting up for so many games year after
year
and that adds up and it just it begins
to wear you down I mean the difference
between our teams in year five compared
to year one in terms of their excitement
level before each game was pretty
dramatic you know our guys were just
kind of wiped out by the end but what it
means physically is hard to quantify I
think Mark Cuban even talked about that
you know what are how can we quantify
you know injury risk in the NBA and and
you know what we do right now is we all
rely on training staffs and and we have
great people on our staff and and you do
the best you best job you can assessing
everything but you know our guys over
the last five years played you know over
a hundred playoff games you know I don't
know how you account for that
what was the move in the offseason that
got your attention
you mean for our team know anybody let's
take your team out of it but you know
the one move where you went oh okay
that's interesting oh I think I think
the Clippers for sure you know getting
getting Kawhi and Paul George I mean it
just because it was you know the getting
both of them at the same time you know
several days after everybody else had
already finished their business and you
know everybody was kind of waiting on on
Kauai and and then to hear Paul George's
name you know in that equation was just
sort of shocking for for everybody you
guys didn't make a run at Kauai well no
it's it's over now it's it's not to talk
about it yeah I still paid ten thousand
bucks back in the day for making a joke
so you try to tee me up for one of these
free agent C jokes it's not happening
he's not
free-agent he's with the Clippers I was
told you guys I was told to keep an eye
on you guys because I thought you were
losing Durant I didn't know you were
getting D'Angelo Russell but I was told
that you guys were not gonna sit by idly
and not do anything so I don't I assume
that you guys did a drive-by with Kauai
and maybe it was just a sneak attack is
that okay can we even broach that topic
that that would be news to me okay you
guys there was no conversation with
Kauai oh okay well then you're not gonna
get fine for that it's gone it's a new
era he would probably find me for the
hand that was now does that come out of
your personal account yes it does yes I
do feel bad about it I do
I'm obviously feel bad we should
probably tell our listeners what we're
talking okay okay you would you ask me
about LeBron it was like during the
season he was in Cleveland this was what
2010 it was like in February he said are
you right I was with tons GM he said you
are you gonna go after LeBron this
summer I said yeah he'll take mid-level
you know I make it joke oh my god I'm
not kidding I wrote a check from my
account from my personal account for
$10,000 to the NBA now what do you say
to your wife I should that's an easy one
for me it's like that's that's a lot
less than you spend now I'm really in
trouble yeah yeah you're not this isn't
a commissioner you got to worry about
it's your life suspension how important
was it getting the draymond Green deal
done now oh it was huge it was huge
because you know what what happened with
our team this year was inevitable in
terms of how many guys we we lost it's
just it's it's going to happen at some
point in the NBA where your team just
you know sort of breaks up and you have
to start a new era but you always want
some continuity and so to have you know
staff clay and draymond still remain the
core of our team going forward it allows
us to transition to that next next step
and and build our the next version of
the worst not to mention the fact that
he just deserves it I mean he's you know
he's been the heart and soul of our team
for for the last five years and one of
one of the key reasons why we've we've
got three championships so I was
thrilled to see dream on rewarded I
don't know if many people know this I do
because I do my homework Steve Kerr once
pitched in a game against Bret
Saberhagen at Dodger Stadium now this
was not when Saberhagen was with Kansas
City Royals by the way how you were high
school when you had this showdown yeah I
was a junior in high school he was he
was a senior City finals 1980 82 LA City
finals that was one of the most fun
experiences of my life despite the fact
that we lost 13 nothing but ended
strange when you face somebody and it's
just different than facing when you face
somebody and you go oh my god that's
different
I don't know how filthy Saberhagen was
back then I'm assuming if he no-hit you
guys but how did you go did you get your
battle on the ball
I did not I didn't get too bad I was I
was the second pitcher who came in we
had a d-h in high school like I don't
know if they still have it or not so I
didn't get to D to bat but the guys were
coming back to the dugout just shaking
their head they said it is just on the
black every time and he you know it's
throwing like 92 in high school on the
black and the one thing I remember it is
it's it's 13 nothing top of the seventh
you know last inning
seven seven inning high school game and
our best hitter gets up in a no-hitter
and tries to bunt his way on
that'll tell you everything about how
great Saberhagen was that day right did
you go up at Dodgers looking like who
did you root for growing up well I was a
huge dodge dad used to take my brother
and me to Dodger games we'd sit in the
in the left-field bleachers and in fact
that's that's still still my team it's
you know as you get older some of the
teams you cheer for you you hang on to
some others you you kind of let go but
as a baseball fan
you know Dodgers are still my team which
I couldn't admit in the Bay Area until
after our second warriors champion you
needed to before you I was I was still
scared after the first one to admit it
but you still do go to Dodger games who
you just even have time to do it or I
try to get to one every summer one of
our owners with the warriors Peter Guber
is on the Dodgers ownership a part of
the Dodgers ownership group as well and
and so he's he's great he invited me to
a game every summer and and I spend a
lot of time in San Diego we have a house
there and that's kind of our home base
and and so usually once a summer I'll
drive up from San Diego and you know
take my wife my son and my son is a big
Cubs fan I'm a Dodger fan so we got to
get good little baseball rivalry going
Steve is of course helping the US Men's
National Team assistant coach before I
let you go let me know what you think of
this this is my scenario here pop
eventually steps down
he's got Tim Duncan on the staff and pop
makes way for Becky Hammon to be the
head coach of the San Antonio Spurs what
do you think be great
I know Becky and she's fantastic and
doesn't it sound like something pop
would do yes it does it does he's always
kind of ahead of the curve and but the
great thing with pop is he just he just
he does stuff without without it see
seeming like a thing you know if he did
it it would just be because Becky's a
hell of a basketball coach
you know then pop wouldn't make a big
deal about look at us you know we're
hiring the first female coach it would
just be no she's a great coach so we're
gonna hire her then he'd move on and and
that was that's what I love about
working with him here you know I've
never worked with him as a coach I
played for him for four years but
there's just there's no pretense with
pot there's no BS it's he's so authentic
and and honest and real and and he just
appreciates good people he appreciates
hard work and effort and people who care
about each other and that's why he
always has an amazing culture that he
sets for his team's because the players
feel that it's great to catch up with
you hope the offseason that you get a
rest here chance to exhale a little bit
and certainly gonna be interesting with
the Warriors with a new look with
DeAngelo Russell and clay eventually
coming back and dream on and the fold
there so but you know what you guys like
challenges we do it's gonna be fun with
the new arena and and got a brand new
brand new season coming but always
always great to hear from you Dan good
to hear your voice thank you Steve and
that's Steve Kerr the Golden State
Warriors head coach for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]